je suis candidat à la présidence de la
république parce que je crois plus que
tout que nous pouvons réussir
brigitte était au premier rang pour
l'applaudir plus il est parti sans
aucune possibilité de l'interroger pour
les journalistes libres
vu que le candidat est parti c'est
sylvain fort qui fait le service
après-vente a prévu il n'a pas prévenu
françois hollande de sa déclaration de
candidature
tu fais partie des responsables
politiques dire hey sont peut-être de
plus en plus rare qu'ils considèrent que
les discussions qui relève de l'intimé
doivent rester dans la sphère de
l'intimé et du personnel arbitres après
la politique politicienne
d'abord la trahison vous avez françois
hollande qui ne l'a poignardée dans le
dos
ce n'est pas une surprise j'ai jamais
pensé qu emmanuel macron marché pour le
téléthon tout le monde savait qu'il
allait être candidat mais je crois que
ce qui est important aujourd'hui faut
retenir la date du 16 novembre
c'est une date historique c'est la fin
du quinquennat françois hollande
ça change la donne d'abord à gauche pour
la première fois de l'histoire la 5ème
république peut être qu'un président
sortant ne va pas être en mesure de se
présenter il porte maintenant une
responsabilité historique
le fait qu'ils aient choisi d'être
candidat lors des primaires eh bien nous
assure à peu près de manière certaine
qu'il n'y aura pas de candidat de gauche
au second tour des élections
présidentielles 2,6 d'abord on
comprendre de quoi on parle
en cas de premier tour pour la
présidentielle 2017 si françois hollande
se présente vous le voyez emmanuel
macron le bas largement l'exercice du
pouvoir
c'est une éthique de responsabilité
c'est savoir tenir bon savoir le sens de
l'intérêt général
le sens du collectif refuser les
aventures individuelles
depuis que j'ai quitté le gouvernement
vous ne m'avez jamais entendu attaqué le
président de la république
contrairement à beaucoup hors du
gouvernement et dans le gouvernement
parfois et compris celles et ceux qui
appellent à la loyauté part il faut de
l'expérience
une expérience qui a été éprouvée par le
temps
il faut de la force et non pas de la
légèreté
beaucoup des gens qu'on a vu appelé à la
loyauté sont d'anciens ministres qui
viennent se battre contre leur président
d'anciens premiers ministres
tout ça n'a aucun sens et je crois que
nos concitoyens on le voit bien monsieur
macro est le candidat des banques et on
a toujours un bon à cette fois ci c'est
celui là
monsieur hollande est quand même venu le
chercher car son guichet de la banque
rothschild cdh incarne le libre-échange
l'ultra libéralisme pur quand j'entends
ce matin par exemple sur france info que
c'est un homme en dehors des partis
c'est vrai en dehors du système c'est
évidemment pas vrai c'est le candidat
des médias puisque il en est à sa 75e
unes de magazines sans avoir fait une
seule proposition il a fait beaucoup de
unis compris dans la presse people
ça n'est pas le candidat du peuple et je
crois que de ce point de vue là non
c'est un candidat qui occupe un créneau
déjà saturé